in this lesson we're going to talk about
how to graph inequalities so this is an
important concept to understand for the
new revised s80 so let's get right into
this video so example number one they
want us to graph the system of
inequalities okay right here so go ahead
and pause the video see if you can do it
on your own and we'll go through it
together so the first thing is when I
look at this top equation it looks like
this is in the slope intercept form of a
line that's you know the y equals MX
plus B form the liner sucked is one so
it's crossing right here at one the
slope is 2 which is like 2 over 1 so I'm
going up to over 1 it's greater than but
not equal to which means that this is
going to be a dashed or a dotted line
like like so when the Y is by itself
like this if it's greater than greater
than means we're shading straight up or
treating shooting above the line greater
than like that okay so that's the first
inequality the second one is more like
in the standard form so what I would do
with for a problem like this because I
would set X 20 to find the y intercept
and I sent why 20 to find the x
intercepts let's do that if x is 0 / 2 y
would be three if y is 0 that means that
x is 2 so I'm just finding where it
crosses the x and y axis so it's
crossing here at three crossing here at
two it's equal to see the equal sign so
I mean this is going to be a solid line
like this okay now we want to figure out
what side of the line to shade we can do
a test point method so you could take
the origin which is zero zero that's
this point right here if we put that
into the inequality here we get zero is
that greater than or equal to 6 well
zero is not greater than or equal to 6
so where this point is that this is the
false region we want to shade on the
other side of the line so if we graph it
you can see they're overlapping right
here so you can go back and shade that
in a little bit darker that's going to
be where the two regions overlap okay so
any point in this region is going to
make this inequality true and the second
inequality true as well now some
students don't like this method of doing
the test point method so if you are one
of those students that's okay just go
ahead and subtract 3x from both sides
divide everything by 2 and so what we're
doing is we're putting it into the
slope-intercept form of the line now
when you draw the line y is greater than
that means
shading above the line okay at lesson is
below because really the Y controls a
vertical Direction X is controlling the
horizontal direction if you prefer that
method just go ahead and put it to the
slope-intercept form the line be careful
though if you divide or multiply by a
negative number remember this inequality
sign changes directions okay so they're
with me so far let's go to example
number two here they give us the system
and it says in the XY plane if a point
with coordinates XY lies in the solution
set of the system of inequalities what
is the minimum possible value of the y
coordinate okay good question so go
ahead and pause the video so you can you
do this problem we'll go through it
together so what is the minimum possible
value of a solution in this to the
system alright so what I would do is
that graph both of these inequality so y
is greater than or equal to X minus 3
that means the y-intercepts negative 3
the slope is 1 i'm going up 1 over 1
okay because you can see this as y is
equal to an extra speed it's in that
form greater than or equal to some users
can be a solid line like this greater
than means I'm shading above the line
right okay so that means it's going to
be on this side of the line I'll just
sketch that in like so all right now the
second line y is greater than or equal
to negative 2x minus 6 this one has a
y-intercept of negative 6 has a slope of
a negative 2 so that means that was
lying down to over 1 or you could go up
to in to the left one like that okay and
this is also greater than or equal to
some of the draw this line and okay like
that approximately and we're shading
greater than so that's shooting above
that's this side of the line right so
I'm just going to draw it like this so
we can see where it's crosshatch you can
see it's in this region right here now
you can see the minimum value the lowest
value is going to be at this point right
here it looks to be negative 1 negative
4 okay so it looks like the Y value the
minimum Y value is negative 4 but if you
want to verify that what you can do is
just treat these like acquaintances
instead of inequalities find that point
of intersection so I'm going to do that
right now so I'm going to say if y is
equal to X minus
let's put that in place of Y so X minus
3 equals negative 2x minus 6 add 2x to
both sides add 3 to both sides and we're
getting X is negative 1 but we want the
Y value so if I put negative 1 back in
we get y is equal to negative 1 minus
three which is negative for you can see
same thing here that would be 2 minus 6
which is negative 4 so the lowest point
here that's still going to be in that
solution set is going to be a y value of
negative 4 so again if you need to
review how to work with graphing
inequalities otherwise i'll see you in
the next lesson